all right it's finally ash Lauren Randy
Pitchford has been talking this game up
but pax's I feel since the dawn of time
something like that yeah your buck
software's first new game in a little
while I guess they had the pre-sequel
came out a couple years ago but yeah
we're sort of big game in about four
years yes yep borderlands 2 was end of
2012 so yeah about four years Yeah right
pre-sequel happened in between but that
was like sort of this weird in-between
game that was pretty fun but wasn't it
was just sort of an iteration on an
existing game they didn't really invent
new mechanics or anything was just like
here's some more borderlands is like a
filler between like the before the next
installment so yeah this is the first
big new thing and then they were busy I
think of publishing home world as well I
think that a couple of little bits and
bobs there but yeah we live in alien
isolation of course it did some other
stuff yeah there was a lot of dlc for
borderlands there was a lot of shirtless
some which was really good so those fans
were satiated for a while and it's gotta
be interesting to see how many of them
make the transition to bottle boring so
you've been playing for the past couple
of weeks on the beta and stuff your
review and progress is live on the site
now yeah went up yesterday okay i set
the review embargo yesterday but
unfortunately the servers weren't live
yet so even though the review embargo
expired we couldn't get on and play
competitive multiplayer so that's mainly
what i'm doing now before i put up the
full review later this week cool so I
guess let's pick your brain about how
you're feeling about it sure all things
considered and hoping that the sort of
online infrastructures is working fine
so yeah right from the top what's your
take on this you've been playing it for
a good long while now yeah what are the
modes you're enjoying I guess for people
who don't know much about the game sort
of what is the meeting potatoes
available yeah so mean as we mentioned
at the top of the show it's the first
person shooter as with everything with
its coming out this month so any first
person shooters yeah we're going to get
as long as possible without mentioning
the oh word we'll talk about it later on
we'll get we'll get okay um but what's
sort of the big hook for battle born for
people who haven't been following is
there are 25 playable characters all of
whom have different abilities and
weapons and all this different stuff and
and only a handful are really
traditional shooter characters that are
you know hold right your left triggered
aim down sight you know pull right
trigger to fire I mean there are a lot
of melee characters a lot of support
characters there's one character whose
real hizzle really job is to run around
in just heal everyone so it's this huge
variety of mechanics and play styles and
gameplay
so that it's it's different for every
single character the thing that I
discovered is if you go into a mission
or it's a multiplayer without having
read up on your character having used
your character before you'll probably
end up feeling very lost because they
are so different you'll not you won't
necessarily know what you're what you're
doing but once you figure out a
character it's it's generally pretty
simple the the game plays is pretty
light very fast-paced very chaotic very
much a classic running gun kind of
Arkady shooter as opposed to something
looks like a little more thoughtful or
cover-based there's a lot about the
design that just encourages you to keep
pressing forward and just run at your
enemies and and every character has
infinite ammo there's no fall damage you
can sprint and reload at the same time
so it's very much about just fast-paced
gameplay and so I guess one questions
coming in a lot has been mentioned here
is am what's the sort of single-payer
component at this game so ya see there
is a large multiplayer component in that
there is like competitive stuff this
cooperative stuff where are we talking
in terms of modes here yeah so there are
eight there's a prologue and then eight
sort of campaign missions okay that are
very clearly designed to be played
cooperatively you can technically play
them so lowly you can I can have to be
certain characters okay you can't go in
as a support character and get through
the missions ezel yeah you want you just
won't be able to make it through I mean
it's several the the missions involve
sort of point defense sections will have
waves of enemies coming you have to
defend something and you don't have more
than just yourself you can't physically
be in enough places to write win or
you'll have like bosses that can fly and
if you don't have a character with
projectile attacks you're kind of
screwed in Thailand and you're probably
not gonna survive so yeah I mean I the
first I might be borderlands borderlands
2 I've soloed the entire thing and I
actually really liked it even though
that game is designed to be cooperative
this game I would really strongly
recommend not playing solo it is meant
to be played with other people it
drastically changes the momentum and
just sort of the fun factor even yeah so
play with other people but yeah so there
eight of those types of missions that
are meant to be played cooperatively and
then there's competitive multiplayer as
well so it's really just those eight
missions that's the single player or
campaign component how longs to take
each mission is anywhere from half an
hour to an hour depending on the mission
I mean I think the longest one takes
about an hour the shore
now and most of them land somewhere
between yeah it's another reason to take
people with you because the missions are
very long and if you're doing it by
yourself it can get a bit long it drags
are we talking about sort of similar to
titanfall or something where there isn't
there not necessarily done in a linear
fashion correct you can kind of do them
in any order if you like raids they feel
like raids rights or something like that
where there there standalone they I mean
there are loose story elements framing
what's going on and depending on the
characters that you bring and you'll get
different banter and a lot of that's
actually really well written it may not
be to everyone's taste like if you
enjoyed the humor in Borderlands there's
a really strong chance we're gonna enjoy
the humor here and it does give it a lot
of character I mean this is very much
like the Saturday morning cartoon of
games yeah it's it's light and it's
funny and silly and goofy can be totally
immature but it's usually stupid in
clever ways that's kind of fun one cool
little touch about it too is there's 25
characters but they all have recorded
dialogue right and it's all different so
they'll all react to like a lot of the
missions our escort the talk to you
robot mmm and they'll all like react the
robot differently depending on who they
are I mean you can really tell they kind
of pour their heart and soul into the
back stories of these characters there's
a really funny mission where you're
escorting a robot who doesn't know
what's going to die and like some
characters are like feel pity and some
characters just don't care and it's like
another one of the robot characters
totally relates to him like it's really
funny how they all act differently in
the dumb as hell and thirsty for death
yeah okay it's funny it's it's sort of
cut every way here in the office talking
to some people like Mary for instance
really enjoyed the stories in the first
two portland and but hasn't enjoyed the
sort of the the nar the story and the
dialogue in this one it falls a little
too close to a saturday morning cartoon
i think she was saying kind of this
morning and I wasn't really super into
board lines but there are like shades of
this thing that I kind of was a little
bit into and you've talked a lot about I
guess what sort of on offer how does it
play though like how engaging is it is
it a game you keep going back to for us
and something you were just reviewing
like I said that the variety really
comes from all of the different
characters maybe we're talking about
this before we went live in my mind it
you know a lot of games will give you
new abilities or weapons as you play
like you know play zelda you get new
stuff all you have the hook shot now
that opens up new options or 4 gameplay
new mechanics that you can use this
kind of does the same thing but each new
mechanic is built into a new character
so as you unlock new characters you
suddenly have new things you can do so
if you get sick of playing as particular
you know melee character you can switch
to more of a sniper range character and
suddenly it's completely different game
I mean the loops are very different
there's a character melka who has like
this gauntlet in one hand and a
automatic pistol on the other and her
loop is she needs to get up close and
melee somebody's that they're like
poisoned and then her gun is more
effective on them okay so she needs to
get in and then get back so that she can
like swipe them but then not take too
much damage but then their other
characters are the exact opposite who
they just need to get in and like be
right in people's faces the whole time
but then there are sniper characters you
know yeah if you get sick of somebody
just switch somebody new and that's
where the variety comes from I think one
of the biggest differences though it's
supposed to borderlands is that you're
asked to upgrade your character every
time you play yes so your character
basically starts at zero you upgrade
through i think there's 10 initial ones
and as you play as you play more of that
character you actually unlock more
things that you can unlock in that train
very much in the style that's why we
want the latest like MOBA style
absolutely nice so it that upgrade as
you go is new to borderland style
gameplay yeah but the shooting and the
flow teenis and the lack of fall damage
like a lot of it will feel very familiar
to people who play borderlands so I
think you know you're getting used to
that character but the actual feel of it
will be familiar for people and so
obviously we've talked about the there's
the single-player aspect which are kind
of like more linear instances whatever
then there's the competitive aspect
which is there's like three different
types of modes yeah currently three
modes the two of them are quite in the
sort of realm of mobile where this creep
and why not and then one of them sort of
a little bit different right yeah so the
the mode that for me I think is gonna
have the most longevity or this may be
the most interesting is also the most
MOBA inspired it's called incursion okay
basically two teams of five are trying
to escort their little minions to a
grinder the other end of the level and
they have to destroy the other teams
minions before they get to their grinder
it's a point battle so whoever can
successfully escort the most minions
wins and yes oh just that structure of
the in match leveling and guiding these
minions and having all of these
different types of characters and so
it's not necessarily symmetrical it does
end up feeling Italy struck
truly a bit like a MOBA though the
gameplay is closer to like a borderlands
e first person shooter stuff on yeah I
find it really fun I mean it definitely
allows the characters to shine a bit
more i mean i found the enemies in the
campaign to be somewhat mindless and
it's it's fine i mean you can almost
think of those missions as as being
practiced almost like a canvas on which
you can you know test out all of these
different abilities these characters
have and it's kind of just fun and just
everything they can do is on display but
then in multiplayer you're suddenly
matched up against other heroes with
equally powerful abilities and weapons
so that's when you kind of have to
really dig into the nuances of the
characters and find different pairings
and different you know complementary
tactics within a team so we'll talk to
some of the negative points in a second
I goop's you ask a quick question though
let's get it out of the way for any
micro transactions in this bad boy not
that I'm aware of doesn't even really
seem like this DLC I know that for like
characters and stuff yeah and i think
they are playing and doing cosmetic
items but none of that's even in the
game currently i'm not even sure how
they would do that there's like a
lootcrate system for mods the mods are
almost equivalent to the shield mods and
borderlands we're right like you you get
mods and then as you farm crystals and
in various matches you have you enabled
and activate the mods and they actually
can balance out certain characters like
certain range characters don't have much
health or shields and you can unlock
mods through the loot crate system to
bolster their their strengths and
weaknesses and then you know show up
their weaknesses so and to be clear that
is separate from the in match leveling
there's sort of like three different
levels of progression in this game which
is very confusing nike yet we've already
dug delving into some of the specifics
on this bad boy let's not get too much
yeah you can it's a very deep rabbit
hole yeah let's talk to some of the sort
of the shortcomings i guess i played a
bunch this morning and played last night
as well almost very frustrated that i
had to do that tutorial mission twice
especially because you cannot skip that
introductory cutting which is like one
of the gravest like like sins in the
game design and i'm sort of it's a game
that like I don't think I'm very much
into these sort of loot shooters anyway
like I was kind of into borderlands
little [ __ ] but I don't really play
alongside other people that that much I
prefer sort of shorter you know
team-based games are like multiplayer
one-on-one sort of games that like wrap
up in like 10-15 minutes so I'm not
really sure if it's for me necessarily
but there was a bunch of things about
this game that just did not like you sit
well with me like for instance a lot of
the game seems to be based around either
standing on capture points or way
killing wave after wave of the same
enemies over and over again it's like a
boring at all I mean it absolutely can
the like I said for me the campaign
missions are almost more like just
practice I again if you think of them as
a canvas on which these characters can
paint with their wild abilities then
they're kind of more palatable but
you're totally right that it is pretty
unimaginative go here defend the thing
wave q wave one wave to you wave three
it's it's pretty routine a lot of the
time yeah and so you're not wrong about
that I mean it becomes a little more
dynamic and competitive multiplayer but
even that there are only three modes and
really only one of those is truly sort
of memorable instructure I mean one of
them is just a really generic capture
and hold point guarding a mode which you
know pretty standard training multiplet
which is fine I mean every game kind of
need something like that but it's hard
to get excited about it really what are
some of the shortcomings you sort of
come across as the reviewer for this
game I mean the one that I think is the
most obvious and to my mind one of the
reasons this game has had a hard time
getting any traction is that it there's
just no real cohesion to it feels very
scattered I mean it pulls from every
influence imaginable and and not just
even in terms of the character mean
obviously the characters are all very
different and if everything from like
high fantasy influence stuff to very
sci-fi looms win stuff but even aside
from that look at the first 20 minutes
the game so that you mentioned that
there's the mandatory sorta opening
mission yeah just within the first three
minutes of the game you get this sort of
like American anime rotoscoping cutscene
thing Alec aeon flux kind of thing yeah
but then there's lots ozik yeah and then
there's in-game cutscenes and then
there's later there's a motion graphic
all within the first 20 minutes of the
game it's like they did just said yes to
every idea it lacks an identity and it
doesn't really kind of gel on a lot of
levels in terms of the gameplay as well
in that first thing they try and do
their best shot I guess to sort of
expose you to a lot of the different
mechanisms are going to play in this
game yeah and there are so many of them
and they're so varied and disparate and
not
of them seem that important but
obviously all of them are a little bit
importance you're like collecting money
to buy on you know pulling turrets in
places yeah and you're you know leveling
up your characters abilities which when
you hit that button to view your
characters abilities it's just a wall of
like so many next of what crazy wall of
text it's just like you know obviously
you can't babysit everyone and there are
certain games were like you need to like
dive into that stuff and just figure it
out and stop being a jerk about it but
there's something about this one it was
just like this too much of that [ __ ]
happening I don't know no III think
you're exactly right I can absolutely
relate to that and I think what almost
makes that worse is that once you do
figure all of that stuff out because you
can I mean it's you know it is a pain
and you do have to read a bunch of stuff
and I recommend you do because you'll be
better off than just feeling like you're
totally clueless and helpless in the
middle of a match but once you figure
everything out once you know a
character's loop you realize that it's
kind of superficial I mean that the
analogy that I've been making to other
people is that you for a lot of games
are for something that's well-designed
it's generally easy to learn it
difficult to master like rocket League
you know immediately intuitive but it
takes a long time to get really good at
ariel's and stuff I feel like this game
a lot of ways is the exact opposite
right where there's a high barrier to
entry where you're just feeling confused
and overwhelmed but once you get a
handle on it it's kind of like okay well
now I realism just kind of spamming the
same attack and waiting for the cooldown
timer to refill and what that does and I
trigger my special again and then I'm
just spamming the attack again and each
character has their own kind of pattern
and once you figure out that patterns it
that's kind of all you do right and you
can switch to a new character and it
kind of refreshes it becomes fun again
but only for a while and it's so you can
absolutely have some light fun with this
and it is crazy and frantic but you're
right that there's this weird learning
curve and then it plateaus and doesn't
stay fun and let's briefly talk about
the other fit in the room I think it's
no coincidence that laser decided to put
the overwatch open beta the day this
game comes out yes savage obviously
Charlie and these games are like there
are lots of similarities and in terms
that they are sort of colorful vibrant
first-person shooters which have a focus
on heroes almost in terms of everything
else they're completely disparate games
like team the overwatch is very much a
team fortress inspired class shooter and
this is sort of doing its own thing
slightly more towards Paragon and and
and then very like broad in terms of its
like single play
narrative and all these other bits and
bobs em you gotta say toe as a consumer
if you're gonna spend 60 bucks on a
shooter me doom is that in a couple of
weeks as well yeah and do you think
gearbox might be a little worried with
this one oh I mean yes I would assume
that they are i mean that's that's some
pretty stiff competition and any month
where you have you know a number of
high-profile triple-a releases that's
already going to be worrying i would
assume for publisher but especially win
it's similar enough that consumers
aren't necessarily going to discern
between them even if as you pointed out
they are actually pretty different games
I would yeah I would have to assume the
gearbox is a little nervous and honestly
it seems like no one's that excited
about nidal born that I'm seeing
including Borderlands fans and kind of a
shame cuz I i do think battleborn is fun
in it and it's doing some creative
things and a lot of work and a lot of
really cool ideas went into it even if
it doesn't work out perfectly as we were
just discussing it is kind of a shame
that it's not getting at least a little
more love from fans but yeah yeah it's a
strange one it kind of feels like a game
does it's it's got its got all that
little parts but it just doesn't root
hasn't really been coming together and
it's a when you think about how long
this game might have been in development
you kind of worried that all they should
have probably had a down by now but yeah
I could see people connecting with
certain characters in the game like I
could see a couple months down the road
you think you're a mushroom person
probably like the mushrooms isn't right
there's some fun characters in there I
think you could have people connecting
with like Phoebe or ND or a couple
characters like I can definitely see
people i could see really landing with
certain people and then them just loving
that one character and wanting to play
one character and showing up at
comic-con dressed as that character like
I think it could have I could think it
could build an audience over time like
be kind of you know more long tail yes
leap Rica yeah I mean it needs to it's a
game this I mean la online right so it
is it's a noise online game so um
probably it's also to be fair like I
think the game's longevity has to do
with its multiplayer components and
those multiplayer components were very
difficult for reviewers and for people
with the the preview bill to get ahold
of they're just worn populating the
matches so I don't know like there might
be more of a long tail in the
multiplayer the single-player seemed to
come down to three mission types of
Scorpia robot hold the point with the
robots you fight a boss yeah yeah so
they are multiple
is worth that and we're gonna have to
see if that connects with people cool
and when is the review going up Scotty
you reckon uh I would seem most likely
on Thursday that's my best guess all
right Scott speech will let you out here
to go play that video game yes Scott
Barbara thank you so much if anyone has
any questions about the game feel free
to hit up Scott on the twitters nut
butter one at butter warm butter womp if
you oh NP love it chase go whomp